lance mccullers has been around now it
feels like forever broke out in 15 he
can be the ace and if he pitches like
that today and continues on he's going
to get his career high in indians he
needs to be that guy for the astros
moving forward
lopez makes contact diving stopped by
bregman he's back
yeah he had to take a little slice of
humble pie signing with the houston
astros but he knew in moving to third
base he was only going to make this team
better we're right out of the shoot
nikki lopez is
testing him and as much as we talk about
alex bregman and what he brings to an
offense you see what he can do
defensively also
that's on the ground right side it's for
el tuve
and the side is retired so perez is
stranded no strikeouts yet in the first
but i'm sure there's plenty of swing and
myths to come from that man this is a
rotation of a bunch of young guys mike
miner is not one of those he's the
veteran they brought him in for a
two-year deal he's their leader
a little flare and caught grabbed by
nikki lopez and shallow left for the
first out that's what nikki lopez does
interesting he came into the season as
their second baseman his job to lose
injuries to uh monday moved him to
shortstop and now he's in contention for
a gold glove this year he's 10 for his
last 20 having a huge home stand
and he whips little chase
miner picks up the strikeout and sits
down the side in order we've completed
one no score eight strikeouts in a 12-3
win last week
and he picks up a strikeout his first of
the day
the one two to taylor he rings him up
two down and made the cut said the
development of the slider has been huge
for lance two adding to our conversation
yeah that's a pitch that suddenly has
become maybe his best weapon
right back to a great athlete on the
mound as well mccullough's junior
impressive second inning
after the dozier base hit through the
right side strikeout strikeout and lance
mccullers jr with the glove to finish
off the royals in the top of the second
takes a pitch on the outside corner
might have missed by a bit he's shaking
his head that is strike three second of
the day for mike miner alex bregman in
the six hole for now
he's back i love him here
i was just gonna ask do you think they
like alex bregman in houston just a
little bit yeah so for bregman it's his
first game since june 16th soft tissue
injuries past couple years really he
said it's been a physical and emotional
roller coaster but he feels better than
he has in the past couple years and goes
after the first pitch
golf swing and foul ground rivera called
off by lopes has a little bump and he's
got it don't mess with the shortstop and
he just got engaged too uh you mentioned
the changeup that's
probably my bread and butter um
maryfield is toast at third nice throw
for martin maldonado i mean this team
can really run not easy to catch whip
merryfell that hasn't happened very
often this season he had the one out
double and then caught stealing for just
the third time this year he has 37
stolen bags second best in baseball you
know what i'm going through lineups
there's a lot of righties in there well
we didn't have much time for you chris
here i'll sneak one in real quick before
we hit the break from sports gaming
universe pitcher player you looked up to
most growing up just the name clayton
kershaw nice i love it maldonado coming
up
maldonado smashes one for the crawford
boxes and beyond
houston's on the board first thanks to
maldi his tenth of the season well he
got his fastball head in the count
middle
and i didn't miss it
salvador perez unloads on that pitch
from lance mccullers jr almost the same
spot as maldonado he goes big both
catchers on either side with home runs
one apiece that's number 34 on the
season for salvi he muscles up he is on
pace to become just the sixth catcher
to hit
40 home runs in this history game
runners going and he is out
maldonado did it again
he catches hunter dozier
this nickname's the machete
cutting runners down
go ball
there it goes jordan alvarez
muscles up it's 2-1 astros
26 on the year flex
this young man can figure out going to
left field in this ballpark it is
frightening
bregman hard contact right center field
and he's in business
to base hit with two outs in the fourth
it's got to feel good for alex getting
back on the board
off goes bregman and tucker is down on
strikes to end the fourth
lansman colors junior picks up another k
it's his fifth of the day lance has
people spinning to the ground right now
he does
it's a roller to correa
and he's got gallagher
three up three down it's a nine pitch
inning for lance mccullers jr
down on strikes mccullers with his sixth
k
of the afternoon
salvia strikes out
there's seven for mccullers salvia knew
it too he knew he was coming
wanted to try and uh
it was just so it was it was so big he
couldn't even reach it because he's
batted well against the breaking ball
this year
always a guy who knows how to make
contact all of a sudden
he's spitting at pitches not that one
but it will
drop fair
and into the seats for a ground rule
double
perfectly placed by euler
i'm not sure you could throw it out
there much better third a b for bregman
today
eighth pitch of the a b is smack to left
field and going back and it's off the
top of the wall
alex bregman's back in a big way with an
rbi double to extend the advantage it's
three to one well i think mike miner
knows about that barrel as well was
trying to stay off it inside pounding
them in pounding them in that one just
didn't get quite to where he was hoping
and credit alex bregman for uh you know
making the adjustment in the outbound
and getting the barrel
two-hat single for michael a taylor
3-2
missed
great out by ray rivera right there sees
it down pretty good job of seeing that
pitch down and not going after it extend
the ending here and put a little
pressure on on dusty as to whether he'll
stick with him
here we go
ball four yanked one and that loads up
the bags for kc and he's gonna face a
new pitcher for houston so mccullers
leaves
with quite the jam here two outs bags
full of royals in the seventh pressure's
on christian javier the 24 year old will
enter the mix here replacing lance
mccullers jr he's actually only
inherited two runners on the season so
this is a unique opportunity for
christian javier
goes after that first pitch it's headed
towards the wall the crawford boxes
forget about it
first pitch grand slam whip merrifield
muscles up and the royals jump in front
5-3 kc
just right if i'm the pitcher i didn't
want to swing at the first pitch anymore
but what
what a gutsy swing
by wit right there comes in the heart
throwing righty and just takes him deep
in on the hands myers
that's well done
myers over to second with two gone in
the seventh
that's in the air and that's gonna fall
and score a run for houston
here comes myers
he's in there on the rbi knock for
oledmi diaz to make it 5-4 to never
underestimate the value of a guy like
olympus diaz
that's a nice swing going the other way
kyle tucker keeps the train rolling
parade a pretty good swing on 97.
barlow's been the man in the late stages
for kc michael brantley pinch hitter in
the nine spot this afternoon for dusty
baker's houston crew brantley center
field he's in business
correa rounding third and
we will tie this game up at five with
the brantley rbi not
what a back and forth affair with these
two
and that is well struck on the ground
and the astros have a two out base
runner in the night
puts one on the ground lopez goes the
short way to merrifield
inning over great job by barlow getting
out of that one there
and tucker going to right and testing
dyson
bragman will stay put at third
they're on the corners with nobody down
in the 10th and here comes young jake
myers the rookie
and that is off the pitcher pie amps
this one's over rbi ground out jake
myers you did it his first career walk
off rbi
astros take it in ten six five